House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
That's Fire And Blood volume 1. The yet unreleased
Fire And Blood volume 2 will continue from
where part 1 ended, with Rhaenyra Targaryen's
son Aegon lll's reign and will cover Blackyre
rebellions, war with Dorne and go all the
way to the Mad King and Robert's Rebellion
that ended Targaryen dynasty.
The key event of the prequel will be the Dance
of the Dragon, a Targaryen civil war.
It's been confirmed that English actor Paddy
Considine will star in the prequel as King
Viserys I Targaryen, a key figure from prelude
to the Dance of the Dragons.
The official description of the character
released by HBO describes him:
“King Viserys Targaryen is chosen by the
lords of Westeros to succeed the Old King,
Jaehaerys Targaryen, at the Great Council
at Harrenhal. A warm, kind, and decent man,
Viserys only wishes to carry forward his grandfather’s
legacy.
But good men do not necessarily make for great
kings.”
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
The Dance of the Dragons was the most devastating
war in the history of the Seven Kingdoms.
A war of succession between Aegon II and his
half-sister Rhaenyra over their father Viserys
I's throne.
Both of them thought they belonged on the
Iron Throne. When people started declaring
for one of them or the other, their fight
divided the kingdoms in two. Targaryens fought
Targaryens, bothers fought brothers, dragons
fought dragons. By the time it was over, thousands
were dead. The conflict would prove to be
incredibly destructive for not only House
Targaryen, but large parts of Westeros as
well. In addition, it devastated the Targaryen's
dragon population, ultimately leading to their
extinction within a few decades.
They never truly recovered.
By the end of the reign of King Viserys I
Targaryen, twenty dragons were alive. The
majority of these died during the civil war
called the Dance of the Dragons, which began
in 129 AC and lasted until mid 131 AC.
One of the main characters in this series
is going to be King Viserys I Targaryen
or at least in season 1 until he dies and
his death starts the Targaryen civil war.
House of the Dragon will not jump straight
into the fighting,
but will rather start with a build-up towards
it, towards the Dance of the Dragons.
It will start with King Viserys l and his
reign. He will live long enough for the series
to introduce us to all the main characters
that are going to be important in the Targaryen
civil war and which side they support as the
future heir, as well as to set up all the
animosity at the court.
Viserys I Targaryen was the fifth Targaryen
King to sit the Iron Throne, ruling from 103
AC to 129 AC.
He succeeded his grandfather, the Old King
Jaehaerys I.
Viserys continued the prosperous peace and
legacy of his grandsire,
but the seeds for the civil war known as the
Dance of the Dragon
that would much later engulf the realm were
inadvertently sown in his reign.
Viserys was a dragon rider who rode Balerion
until the dragon died of old age during the
reign of Jaehaerys I. Viserys never bonded
with another dragon after Balerion's death.
Let's get a bit back to explain how Viserys,
who was not a son of a King
nor a son of King's eldest son, became a King.
When King Jaehaerys I Targaryen's son and
heir, Prince Aemon, died in 92 AC,
Jaehaerys chose Aemon's younger brother, Prince
Baelon, as his heir, passing over Aemon's
daughter, Princess Rhaenys.
However, Prince Baelon died as well in 101
AC while serving as Hand of the King,
leaving behind him two sons, Viserys and Daemon.
The Old King once again needed an heir.
With Jaehaerys I in decline and unable to
choose his new heir after Baelon's death,
a Great Council was held in 101 AC at Harrenhal
to determine who would succeed him.
Aemon's daughter Rhaenys was a candidate,
as were her children Laenor and Laena Velaryon.
But the council ruled in favor of Viserys
I, given that he was Baelon's heir,
and Jaehaerys had favored Baelon over his
granddaughter Rhaenys.
And so the Old King named Viserys his heir,
the new Prince of Dragonstone
and upon the Old Kings death, Viserys became
a new King.
House Targaryen was at its most powerful during
Viserys's time,
having the most members and dragons since
the Doom of Valyria.
Viserys was known as the Young King when he
ascended the Throne.
Holding a court with Queen Aemma Arryn, the
Young King was determined to maintain the
peace and goodwill of his grandfather Jaehaerys
the Wise.
They had a son who died in infancy and a daughter,
Princess Rhaenyra who was six when her father
became a king. The princess became his royal
cupbearer at the age of eight
and was always by her father's side at feasts,
balls, and tourneys.
Rhaenyra was dubbed "the realm's delight".
Viserys's younger brother, Prince Daemon Targaryen,
one of the most dangerous men in the Seven
Kingdoms, considered himself his brother's
heir
and coveted the title Prince of Dragonstone.
While Viserys loved Dameon the Rogue Prince
despite his flaws, he had no wish for Daemon
to succeed him.
Viserys was hopeful that his wife would give
him a son soon and settle the succession issue.
Viserys appointed his brother on the small
council, but the rivalry between Daemon and
the Hand of the King, Ser Otto Hightower,
became so great … that Viserys in early
104 AC appointed Daemon to be Commander of
the City Watch to remove Daemon from the small
council.
Fearful of Daemon becoming a king, Otto tried
to convince Viserys to make Rhaenyra his heir.
Viserys refused, as he was confident he and
his wife would one day have a son.
Aemma later became pregnant, to the king's
delight. In 105 AC Aemma died in labor birthing
the king's son and heir, whom Viserys named
Baelon after his late father, Prince Baelon,
but the infant died a day after Aemma. While
the king was mourning, his brother Daemon
was observed making drunken japes with his
company about the "heir for a day".
When word of this reached the grieving Viserys,
his grief turned to rage.
After, when the mourning period was over,
Viserys held a lavish ceremony in 105 AC
and had Rhaenyra declared the heir and Princess
of Dragonstone
in response to his ungrateful brother's ambitions.
Hundreds of lords and landed knights swore
fealty to the princess and swore solemn oaths
to defend her rights of succession.
Daemon left the capital in a fury. Viserys
began to groom Princess Rhaenyra to be the
ruling queen, teaching her how to rule and
made her part of his small council.
Since Viserys was not yet thirty, Grand Maester
was the first to urge him to remarry
and so he did to Alicent Hightower, the eighteen-year-old
daughter of Ser Otto Hightower,
his Hand of the King. Viserys and Alicent
married in 106 AC.
Rhaenyra and Alicent at first got on well,
but that soon changed.
When Daemon and House Velaryon fought a war
for control of the Stepstones against the
Triarchy,
the peaceful Viserys was unperturbed.
The fertile Alicent bore a healthy son, Aegon,
in 107 AC.
A daughter, Helaena followed in 109 AC and
another son named Aemond was born in 110 AC.
The good relations between Queen Alicent and
Princess Rhaenyra soon ended
as both desired to be the realm's first lady,
and there could only be one.
Although Alicent had given Viserys male heirs,
the King did nothing to change the order of
succession
as he considered the matter already settled
by naming Rhaenyra in his will.
Otto Hightower tried to pursue The King to
change his heir from Rhaenyra to Aegon
so much that Viserys sent him back to Oldtown,
bestowing the position of Hand on Lyonel Strong.
Two parties began to form at court. The queen's
party consisted of powerful lords friendly
to Alicent
and supportive of the rights of her sons.
Against that was the party of the princess,
those who supported Rhaenyra as heir.
In 111 AC, a great tourney was held at King's
Landing on the fifth anniversary of Viserys's
marriage to Alicent. During the opening feast,
Queen Alicent wore a green gown,
while Princess Rhaenyra dressed in the red
and black of House Targaryen.
The note was taken, and soon all of Rhaenyra's
supporters started wearing black clothing,
while all of Alicent's followers started wearing
green.
Over the years, the popular names applied
to both factions were inspired by the colors
they wore: Rhaenyra's supporters were called
"the Blacks", and Aegon II's supporters were
called "the Greens".
The tourney also saw the return to the court
of Prince Daemon,
who reconciled with Viserys offering him the
crown he claimed
while fighting for the Stepstones, but six
months later Daemon was exiled again from
King's Landing. While Grand Maester Runciter
claimed the two brothers simply got into a
fight,
it was rumored that Daemon took Rhaenyra's
virginity and that Hand of the King counseled
the furious King Viserys that Daemon should
be executed for treason.
Septon Eustace reminded the council about
the taint of kingslaying, thus Daemon was
exiled instead.
Viserys hated conflict and made repeated attempts
to cease the hostilities between the greens
and the blacks, with many fights and false
apologies issued on both sides.
He loved his wife and daughter equally, but
they only loved each other when he commanded.
So long as Viserys ruled, peace prevailed
in the Seven Kingdoms.
In 113 AC Viserys decided it was time for
his daughter Rhaenyra to wed.
Queen Alicent wanted the princess to wed her
eldest son, Aegon, so he could one day be
a king.
Viserys would not hear of it, as Aegon was
ten years Rhaenyra's junior
and the two had never got on well.
The king and council chose Laenor Velaryon
to wed Rhaenyra to re-gain the friendship
between the Iron Throne and Velaryons. Rhaenyra
however, protested the match,
stating Laenor would prefer her "half brothers"
instead of her.
Rhaenyra yielded only after Viserys threatened
that if she did not accept the marriage,
he would change the succession.
So in 114 AC a reluctant Rhaenyra wed Ser
Laenor,
although it is questioned if the marriage
was ever consummated.
Laenor spent most of his time on Driftmark,
surrounded by handsome squires
and infrequently visited Rhaenyra on Dragonstone.
Later the same year Rhaenyra gave birth to
her first son, Jacaerys Velaryon.
However, due to the babe not having the traditional
Valyrian features of either of his parents,
Laenor and Rhaenyra both had light silver/gold
hair and purple eyes,
rumor spread that the child's real father
was her lover Ser Harwin Strong,
the strongest man in Westeros called Breakbones
and Rhaenyra's sworn shield who resided with
her on Dragonstone.
Queen Alicent bore a third son, Daeron, to
King Viserys the same year.
Viserys got two more grandsons years later
by Rhaenyra,
Lucerys Velaryon born in 115 AC and Joffrey
Velaryon in 117 AC.
All three of Rhaenyra's children had pug noses,
brown hair, and brown eyes,
further spreading the belief throughout the
kingdom that the children's real sire was
Ser Harwin Strong.
The Greens were the ones who sparked this
rumor, often calling them Strongs.
Prince Daemon and his wife, Laena Velaryon,
had twin daughters named Baela and Rhaena.
The brothers Daemon and Viserys reconciled
a second time and with the blessing of the
king Princess Rhaenyra betrothed Jacaerys
and Lucerys to Baela and Rhaena.
The year 120 AC became known as the Year of
the Red Spring because of its many deaths
and accidents. Laena Velaryon, the wife of
Prince Daemon Targaryen, died after a failed
birth.
At her funeral, a quarrel broke out between
Aemond Targaryen and the sons of Rhaenyra,
who were accused of being bastards from House
Strong.
Aemond lost an eye when Lucerys defended Jacaerys
with a knife.
The false apologies from the families of Rhaenyra
and Alicent fooled no one, but Viserys.
The king issued an edict that anyone spreading
the Strong rumor would lose their tongue,
and ordered Ser Harwin Strong to depart from
Dragonstone to Harrenhal.
Afterwards, a massive fire at Harrenhal killed
Harwin and his father Lyonel,
the Hand of the King. While some blamed it
on the curse of Harrenhal,
others whispered that Daemon, Lord Corlys
Velaryon, and even Viserys were responsible
for the blaze.
The king recalled Ser Otto Hightower as the
King's Hand.
The year also saw the death of Rhaenyra's
husband, Laenor Velaryon,
killed in a fight between his companion and
lover, Ser Qarl Correy
who many whisper was hired by Daemon to do
so.
Rhaenyra and Daemon shocked the realm by wedding
without Viserys's knowledge,
a huge scandal, as neither Laena nor Laenor
had been dead for six months.
It made Viserys furious. It took some time
before Viserys and Daemon reconciled.
The year ended with Rhaenyra and Daemon welcoming
the birth of their first son,
Prince Aegon the Younger. Another son, born
in 122 AC,
was given the name Viserys after Rhaenyra's
father, King Viserys himself.
Rhaenyra's sons by Daemon and all had Targaryen
features.
The forced closeness of Rhaenyra's and Alicent's
children increased animosity between the blacks
and greens. The royal children and grandchildren
became Dragonriders
and court visitors observed the dragons of
one faction
snapping and spitting flames at the dragons
of the other party.
Viserys died on the third day of the third
moon of 129 AC
during a nap in the Red Keep of King's Landing.
On his death bed, he refused to change the
succession and decreed his heir to be Rhaenyra.
He was found dead by a servant who first went
to Alicent to inform her of Viserys's death,
which proved to be a grave mistake as Alicent
proclaimed Aegon the King over the wishes
of Viserys.
At the time of her father's death, Rhaenyra
was on Dragonstone.
The greens in King's Landing ensured that
the news of the Viserys's death did not reach
her
until her own supporters in the Red Keep were
dead or imprisoned
and Aegon II's coronation had already occurred.
King Viserys decreed Rhaenyra to succeed him,
but Aegon the Elder, the eldest son of his
second wife Alicent, was instead crowned Aegon
II by Ser Criston Cole, the Lord Commander
of the Kingsguard.
This led to a civil war between Rhaenyra and
Aegon , the Dance of the Dragons.
The devastating civil war that tore apart
the Seven Kingdoms.
The war lasted for three years, and by the
time it came to an end thousands were dead,
nearly all of the Targaryen dragons had been
killed as well as many Targaryens themselves.
King Viserys I will be the main character
in the first season and upon his death,
the realm will explode into a massive civil
war between the Blacks and the Greens,
the Targaryen civil war known as the Dance
of the Dragons.
20 major battles, even more smaller battles
and even more betrayals, turncloaks, and twists.
All of that and more this Game of Thrones
prequel show, House of the Dragon, brings
in 2022.
Let me know your thoughts about everything:
the prequel, its characters, especially King
Viserys,
in the comment section down below.
Thank you so much for watching and I hope
to see you in the next one.
Peace!